[Music]
for a game with as morbid of premise as
the Hitman franchise a series that's
built off the back of silenced pistols
and fire the 2016 reimagining of the
barcode barring Baldy embraced more of
the slapstick silliness that is now
possible with the extra creativity and
variety that hitman and hitman two
brought to the table previous games have
always had level of creativity and
always had moments that were a bit daft
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but I don't think that particular
wrinkle of the game was fully expanded
on until the most recent iterations that
point shines on truer than ever with
agent 47s carry an item his weaponized
luggage that trusty briefcase now the
main purpose of this particular item in
the game was a way to covertly carry
weapons and gadgets around the sprawling
maps of hitman two without innocent
bystanders and eagle-eyed security
guards taking notice but whether or not
the development team I've interacted
intended it to be or not it has become a
handheld heat-seeking cuboid of carnage
for those of you who are unaware if you
lock onto an enemy while holding a blunt
or sharp object and hit man to the throw
will guarantee a headshot to kill or
incapacitate whoever is unlucky enough
to be on the receiving end of it which
works great when you throw a cola cannon
to someone's face or sling a fast-moving
throwing knife into someone's gray
matter but for agent 47 slower spinning
attache had some unexpected effects
if you've been on reddit Twitter
Instagram YouTube or pretty much
anywhere that you can find daft gaming
videos you may have seen em pcs
haphazardly running away from whirling
luggage with players going as far as
clearing whole levels with the thing now
I don't like to do the whole well that's
not how it would work and real-life
thing when it comes to talking about
video games but let's be real here it's
something wrong that suitcase man and
because I'm either a a massive nerd or
be I just can't let dumb funny things be
dumb funny things I went right to the
source and actually had a chat with IO
Interactive to find out what was up with
agent 47s possessed personal belongings
now there's one person who is an expert
on ballistic briefcases and that is
Viktor Novica sorry that is Jacob
Nicholson the briefcase what just what's
going on with that man what's briefcases
don't work that way well a lot of stuff
I have to say yeah it's a I think it's
been they're quite hilarious to see it
see the reaction to the briefcase and
tend to be on this round it's like it's
kind of a bit more extreme that we
expected right but for me it's just it's
just great to see how much fun people
are having with it and kind of see the
reactions and then and you know you go
on read it and then there's like oh I oh
please don't touch this and then they're
just having a blast with it right and I
think it's for me it's very much in the
vein of the game right that would give
you a tool set and then then you do with
it what you can and yeah so so beginning
to see some some crazy videos of what
people can do with the brief day now
technically right it's an extension of
the throwing mechanics we had in 2016 so
it's working with the same systems as
all the thrown crops are the fish the
Knights the Hurricanes and whatnot right
so so there's just something about the
briefcase but that makes it kind of by
this sign that when you get the log on
and you hit the robot and then you're
gonna hit whatever you're aiming
right but but the briefcase speed seems
slower than the rest so so that's kind
of it's one of these where as I said
reflected in the beta of the game where
the systems are kind of doing what
they're doing and then the result turns
out to be this and I think that that's
hilarious
one player he actually planned it a
breaching charge on the ground
place the briefcase on top and then
detonate the brief hit the the breaching
charge and then launches the suitcase
into the air and that's that's kind of
one of the other properties of its kind
of affected by these physics impulses
but the trick is he then planted a
remote explosive inside the suitcase so
it gets kind of little ants where the
target is and then he detonates it so it
turns it into a kind of a hand grenade
in a way and that's not something we
have kind of design per se we came up
with the systems and the functionality
and then the useless kind of can't craft
these these mechanics themselves and I
think that that's where the game really
shines
target eliminated so obviously you
touched on the community asking the
important question but do you have any
plans to change this when I knew I knew
you would be answering that and and
we're not ready to talk about that I'm
yeah that yes pick up because I let that
because I think it's it's you know on
one idea you could go in and just and
then just Pat it out and say no we're
not gonna do that but then we're kind of
like who would benefit from that right
so the question is what what what with
the next step for this in case be and I
think that's that's a that's that
interesting
would you consider doing like a suitcase
only elusive target the live thing is
that the team is working on that and
right now we're not we're not kind of
talking about the details of all the
elusive targets and everything however I
think that it will have to see the cool
thing about the live part is that we can
react to to what the users are doing
right to go and read it there's another
theme right now which is about Diana
pointing out targets where they every
time Lana sees a target she says that is
Sharon Knox that is that is so the word
bet is becoming a meme on reddit as well
where where Danna it's commenting things
out for these player for the players and
so they pick up these themes and then
they they they they play around with it
they create the gifts and and all this
and I think that that's one of the
things where it's like in one way or the
other I think it's time we totally
succeeded in doing something great when
people do this right where they kind of
dive into this and just kind of have fun
with it so so I think again this is back
to the to the working with the players
kind of indirectly and directly as well
I'm talking to them about what what they
would like and all that stuff but but
it's one of these things where if I
think it's something about you know
don't explain exactly what we're gonna
do but look at what they're doing and
then react to that in certain ways I
think that that's at the the strongest
way of doing this because then we can
kind of I really like it when we go in
and we kind of we put a little I saw
that in the game for the players to plan
so so I would say I yeah I can't sell
any details about that just that so
there you have it a story behind him and
two's magical briefcase now no one out
there can accuse me of not doing any of
that serious investigative journalism
stuff but if you liked this video make
sure you let me know in the comment
section below or you can fire
me on Twitter at a regular day even feel
free to let me know what daft weird
assassinations you've been up to in
hitman two until then I'll see you in
the next one
[Music]